the genius is a word that gets used so
much more feminine I've always found
that word very problematic I'm here to
change that is here we are I was doing a
lot of 3d animation and 3d modeling but
just like seeing something that you
modeled in a virtual space coming to
life from its digital space to a
physical space layer by layer I just
thought that's that's crazy that you can
just do that I was doing a lot of
research around how oil relates to both
jihad but also like capitalism and then
the video of Isis destroying artifacts
at Michonne museum came out I was like
okay how can I like relate this because
everything that I'm reading right now
everything that I'm working on is is
about this like right destruction and
how the 3d printer didn't become this
this machine that reversed these
[Music]
we were creating them based on images
and once I started to do research and
these artifacts that were destroyed I
realized that there was such a lack of
information about them
I contacted so many historians of
scholars that specifically work on hats
raw or Massoud I wanted to find a way
that I would share that give access both
to kind of the sculptures but also these
information that I gathered so inside
each artifacts there is a memory card
and a flash drive that is embedded that
contains all the information PDF files
images videos even my email
correspondence with different scholars
the more people read about it the more
people printed those pieces the more
people have been saved on their
computers the more these things will get
saved and remembered I was really
interested in figuring out what are the
material that I can use that would be
the closest to the origin material which
was like actually like a stone more like
dense material right
I just thought resin would be cool
because like it almost looks like a
ghost of these objects I've only had
seen at that point the object in a
digital space in a virtual space and
then seeing it in a physical space is a
very different experience so I just
remember opening the door of the 3d
printer and having this thing printed
but it would be so much like support
material around that so it almost felt
like dug and in the ground it was very
like archeological in some ways there's
really no way to replace these objects
that were destroyed to me that's where
like the beauty of that project was when
I could just use the technology to
archive something that was meant to be
lost or destroyed
all the stories of superheroes are 99%
about men we have like very little
figures that are super here is that our
women I was looking to find these female
dark goddess figures different mythical
narratives based in the Middle East
bringing them back not just
reappropriation they're the form and
sculpture but also refiguring their
stories if you want to like imagine
other kind of futures I think you need
new figures new stories new histories to
use as a point of departure I obviously
like news technologies I have a lot of
hope around that and what's possible
with it but I also think there's like a
very dark side of it which is that who
gets to have access to both technology
and use it in what way but also you can
make small changes I really really do
believe in the power of micro changes
for macro influence
[Music]
[Music]
Oh